digamos que tomamos nuestro tennessee en
lugar de dejarlo en el suelo y
imaginemos que lo vamos a empujar contra
la pared la pared va a ser una fuerza
normal de la misma manera que lo haría
el suelo pero cuando esto sucede y las
personas comienzan a preocuparse un
poquito ya que el problema se vuelve un
poco más extraño digamos que tenemos una
fuerza diagonal aquí que llamamos f4
esta fuerza evita que el tenis caiga
pero también empuja el tenis contra la
pared por lo que vamos a tener de nuevo
una fuerza normal vamos a decir que aquí
hay un ángulo y este ángulo es fi y aquí
la pregunta es cuál será la fuerza
normal en este caso en este problema es
un poquito más extraño pero podemos
resolverlo de la misma manera
primero dibujamos nuestro diagrama de
fuerzas siempre es una buena práctica
dibujar cuáles son las fuerzas
involucradas aquí
y vamos a tener nuestra fuerza normal
pero primero deberíamos dibujar nuestra
fuerza de gravedad la gravedad es fácil
siempre va a apuntar hacia abajo por lo
que tenemos m por g hacia abajo y vamos
a tener una fuerza normal pero muchas
personas se equivocan aquí van a querer
dibujar la fuerza normal hacia arriba
normalmente va hacia arriba porque
muchos problemas se plantean en contacto
con el suelo con una superficie
horizontal pero ahora esto está en
contacto con una superficie vertical y
la palabra normal en la frase fuerza
normal no se refiere a algo aburrido o
común se refiere a normal en el sentido
matemático sinónimo de perpendicular
perpendicular a la superficie que ejerce
esta fuerza en este caso la superficie
es la pared es vertical y lo
perpendicular a la pared va a salir de
esta pared y se va a mover hacia la
derecha por lo que
el muro va a empujar el zapato hacia la
derecha para evitar que el zapato se
meta en la pared y esto puede parecer
algo raro tenemos una fuerza normal que
va hacia la derecha y tengo otra fuerza
que es mi f4 y dibujo mi fuerza f 4 que
luce así
estas son mis fuerzas son las únicas
fuerzas que tengo aquí y aquí no vamos a
tener fricción vamos a suponer que el
zapato está quieto en la pared y ahora
queremos encontrar la fuerza normal
crecemos de nuevo vamos a usar la
segunda ley de newton a es igual a la
fuerza neta entre la masa y esto es en
cierta dirección en este caso vamos a
usar la dirección horizontal ya que la
fuerza que queremos encontrar la fuerza
normal está de la dirección horizontal a
que va a ser igual mi aceleración en la
dirección horizontal pues si pensamos en
esto como estoy empujando el zapato en
la pared lo más probable es que no tenga
ninguna aceleración horizontal incluso
aunque se estuviera resbalando hacia
arriba y hacia abajo lo más probable es
que no se esté metiendo hacia la pared
por lo que lo más seguro es que se quede
quieto en el plano de este muro por lo
que no vamos a tener ninguna aceleración
horizontal es decir no voy a tener
ningún movimiento en la dirección
horizontal puedo tenerlo en la vertical
pero no en la horizontal
no hay ningún cambio en la velocidad
aquí en la dirección horizontal ya que
el zapato no se va a estar moviendo en
esta dirección
así que nuestra aceleración horizontal
va a ser cero esto es igual a la fuerza
neta dividido entre la masa y cuál es la
fuerza neta horizontal tengo fm que va
hacia la derecha como va hacia la
derecha voy a considerarla como una
fuerza positiva y demi f4 una parte de
esta fuerza va a empujar hacia la
izquierda y como lo hice antes voy a
descomponer esta fuerza en sus elementos
horizontales y verticales una parte de
esta fuerza funciona horizontalmente y
otra parte de esta fuerza funciona
verticalmente para encontrar esta eje 4
en la dirección x que es lo que tengo
que poner en mi fórmula de acá ya que es
el componente que me interesa en esta
dirección sólo me interesa la fuerza
horizontal el componente vertical no lo
estoy considerando recordamos que
estamos considerando nuestra segunda ley
de newton en la dirección horizontal
solo
para despejar efe 4x voy a usar mi seno
ya que este ángulo está opuesto a este
lado por lo que voy a usar seno de fi
que es igual a efe 4 en la dirección x
entre la hipotenusa que es mi fuerza
total
efe 4 efe 4 en x va a ser igual
a efe de 4 por el seno de fin
y ahora voy a usar esto aquí arriba pero
tengo que tener cuidado con los signos
esta efe 4x va hacia la izquierda por lo
que debo considerarla como negativa aquí
escribo menos f 4x por el seno de fin
multiplico ambos lados por m me sigue
quedando 0 en el lado izquierdo que es
igual a fm menos f 4x seno de fi y ahora
cuando despejó fn mi fuerza normal me
queda que mi fuerza normal es igual a
efe 4x por el seno de fi
ya que es un este f4 seno de fi en ambos
lados de la ecuación y eso tiene sentido
ya que lo que está pasando en esta
superficie y la razón por la que tenga
una fuerza normal es porque cualquiera
que sea la fuerza que están ejerciendo
estas superficies entre sí van a evitar
que el objeto atraviese la superficie
efe 4x seno de finn está empujando hacia
la superficie por lo que la fuerza
normal tiene que equilibrar esto tienen
que tener la misma magnitud para evitar
que haya alguna aceleración al menos
horizontalmente y aquí no hay otras
fuerzas involucradas podríamos agregar
más fuerzas y ustedes ya saben qué hacer
en este caso si agregamos otra fuerza
aquí que llamamos f5 aquí habría otra
fuerza en nuestro diagrama f5
y ustedes ya saben cómo tratar esto aquí
estaría la fuerza apuntando hacia la
izquierda por lo que nuestra ecuación la
pondríamos con signo negativo
- efe 5
aquí también estaría - efe 5 tendríamos
que sumar la en ambos lados lo que nos
queda que aquí sería un más
efe 5 qué pasa si sumamos una fuerza
vertical tendríamos esta fuerza hacia
arriba que llamamos efe 6 pues esto no
me va a afectar mi fuerza normal
horizontal está efe 6 no me está
afectando como se están empujando
mutuamente estas superficies así que
esto ni siquiera lo considero esta
fuerza vertical no me estaría afectando
mi fuerza normal que en este caso es
horizontal y también aquí la gravedad no
me está afectando esta fuerza normal ya
que la gravedad estaría ejerciendo su
fuerza de forma vertical y me fuerza
normal está en la dirección horizontal
así que en pocas palabras la fuerza
normal no siempre es m porque la fuerza
normal sólo va a existir o va a ser
diferente de cero cuando tenemos dos
superficies en contacto que se están
empujando mutuamente podemos cambiar el
valor de la fuerza normal agregando
fuerzas que afecten a esta superficie y
que actúen sobre este objeto y si
tenemos alguna fuerza con un ángulo para
calcular la fuerza normal debemos
asegurarnos de sólo usar el componente
de esta fuerza en ángulo
está ejerciendo en la dirección de
nuestra fuerza normal ya que será la
única que va a afectar a este y para
despejarlo vamos a usar la segunda ley
de newton